لقد كنت جزءًا من الفريق الذي حقق الفوز المزدوج عام 2004
هناك مع بعض اللاعبين المذهلين ،
فكيف يمكن لهذا الجيل الجديد من IAC أن
يقارن كما تعلم عندما أعود إلى
فريقنا ، لقد كنا أقوى بدنياً من
كرة القدم ، لقد تغيرت كرة القدم ، وكنا أكبر بكثير
كل منا كنا عظماء الآن  لقد
شرحت الأمر بشكل مختلف قليلاً قبل
أن يكون لدينا الكثير من المدربين القادمين
ومع الهدف الحقيقي رقم 9 الآن
يلعبون أكثر بين السطور
ويدخلون الكرة أكثر في
الملعب ويظهر لك أن كرة القدم قد
تغيرت  قليلاً لكن هذا الفريق حصل على
الكثير من
الجودة ، فقط في كل مرة تأتي فيها الكرة إلى
الشباب ، أردت فقط
أن أبقى في قدميه لفترة
أطول قليلاً ، إنه لمن دواعي سروري أن أشاهد
ما هو
لاعب بالطبع.  التوجه إلى مكان آخر في
نهاية الموسم لاعب آخر
نفس الشيء الذي يتم الحديث عنه هو الجرم الذي
يبلغ من العمر 19 عامًا ، ما
مدى تميزه في القيام بما يفعله ،
كما تعلم ، فقد أخطأ في ذلك
الهدف الأول في المباراة الأخيرة ولكنه تخطى.
نحيناها جانباً
وأحدثوا الفارق ، نعم يا لها من
شخصية قوية ويجب أن يكون
فخوراً للغاية - كابتن هذا الفريق ونصف
نهائي دوري أبطال أوروبا
و- لإخراج QV وإخراج ريال
مدريد ، يجب أن يكون فخوراً للغاية  كلهم
لأكون صادقين ، رسالتي إليهم -
استمتع فقط ولأنهم في هذه الأيام
هم فيها سيتذكرون دائمًا وكانوا دائمًا سيفخرون
بهم